hello everyone and welcome to the game
everyone is talking about it is of
course versus Anish giri from
yesterday's aim chest preliminaries it
is round three and both of them are
having a a nice tournament so far a
mamidara especially since he defeated
Magnus Carlsen in the in the first round
uh Anish defeated the visit and now they
face each other in the third round it's
quite a game many pieces are are getting
sacrificed everything is hanging and
it's uh well it's just a a very nice
game so let's dive straight into it
mamidaro has the white pieces and he
opens with D4 we have Knight to F6 sorry
about that uh and uh now there are a
couple of uh well moves that come to
mind here like uh C4 is something we see
very often Knight to F3 something we see
Bishop to g5. trumpovski also something
we see fairly often but Knights the C3
it's a bit uh rare it's only the fourth
most popular continuation but um you
know for a rapid game people uh people
will use it so here Pawn to the five
bionish and the bishop to F4 we have
pawned the E6 and now the immediate
Knight to B5 going after the C7 pawn and
yes this does look like something you
would try against your uncle but it's
actually perfectly fine so next the A6
um defending the C7 Pawn Ponte E3 and
now Bishop to E7 we have Pawn to H4
now there is only one game in the
database where Pawn to H4 was played and
it was played this year in the Abu Dhabi
uh not in Abu Dhabi in the Sharjah
Masters between uh Arjun irrigation
uh that ended in a draw I believe but
here we have uh castles also uh as it
was played in their game night to a 3 C6
Knight back to C3 and now in that game
that I've mentioned uh martiros and
played Bishop to D7 but here we have
Queen to B6 by a niche and it is now as
of move 8 that we have a completely new
game so the B2 Pawn is hanging but um
not really uh A3 by mamidyarov and now
you can't capture the pawn if you
capture a pawn just Knight A4 and the
queen hangs so that's not what Anish
will do Anish of course strikes against
the center he plays Pawn to C5 and now
Bishop captures an A6 Queen captures and
now it seems like uh you maybe you
shouldn't have just given up your light
Square Bishop like that now the queen
also prevents the white king from cast
link but that only matters if you're
planning the castle my major just pushes
H5
so H6 is stopping any further
advancement of the pawn and now Pawn to
G4 just going all out here preparing G5
also probably one of the reasons as the
Black Point in is so far away from the
King side uh maybe she will not be in
time to help out with the defense of the
black king and also I think what is even
more important than mamidaro did beat
Magnus Carlsen in the first run so of
course now everything must Bend to his
will and naturally he pushes G4 we have
Knight captures on G4 it's a free Pawn
so why not Anish captures it Rook to G1
and now Pawn to F5 uh cementing that
Knight on G4 mom made out of attacks and
knights the E5 and now C captures on D4
attacking the Knight on C3 uh Shakira
recaptures and now we have Bishop to F6
and now
uh how do you how do you play this the
problem is uh you really want to open up
the G file for The Rook but if you play
Knight captures on G4 and F cat person
uh for example Rook captures then a nice
E5 and you can resign this as a white so
uh although you want to break through
this is not the way to do it so Mama
Madeira finds a way to do it and he
plays Rook captures on G4 keeps the
Knight alive uh F characters on G4 and
now Queen captures on G4 and now uh okay
uh you know Bishop counters on H6 is
coming this is definitely a threat uh
but if you play something like King the
h8 you don't really uh gain all that
much plus the white can just whenever a
white ones playing ig6 check pick up the
Rook here so instead we have Pawn to B5
by an initial later on you can play the
Queen to B7 you can add the queen to
help out with the defense of the king
side plus also we want to play A5 B4 and
so on so Bishop captures an H6 for the
moment that this bishop is guarding G7
so it's not a problem Queen to B7 and
now Queen side castles
starts with a 5 prepares B4 and now
Knight captures on B4 just giving up a
full night to get rid of the Queen's
control over the G7 Pawn but even if you
don't capture this Knight the D6 is
coming so you might as well capture it
so here Queen captures on B5 and now
Bishop characters and G7 mommy there are
just giving up all of his pieces Bishop
catras on G7 and now Ponta H6 preparing
Checkmate here with Queen captures on G7
but Rook day seven another problem black
is up in material and now the next move
is key there are many many nice
moments where we could have made it a
pause the video moment but I think this
one is the nicest so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only
winning move for mamidyarov while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding the the
forced mating 2 although not a forced
one it's the first one only if uh you
know Anish allows it and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook the H1 that's preparing the
force mating two uh because now let's
say you play something like rule B7 you
go after the B2 Pawn is it's just a
matter of H7 check only will King h8 and
Knight the G6 is Checkmate so that's why
Rook to H1 is so powerful so here we
have Rook captures on F2 uh freeing of
the f8 square for the blacking so you
don't have to go to h8 so H7 check King
to f8 and now like I said there are many
moves that you can play here to win the
game but mamidaro of course chooses the
nicest one he wants the uh well he wants
everyone uh to to say after the game
will be shown online that he sacrificed
his Queen at least once so he plays
Queen captures on G7 but you could do
many other things you could play h8
promoto Queen h8 promotes to a rook and
any more fine here Queen cat percent G7
is played a rook captures on G7 and now
h8 Queen again the the king is in check
the Rook is hanging so Rook to G8 and
now Knight the G6 check again the only
winning move very interesting Knight the
G6 check and now how do you play this if
you try to defend the Rook that of
course doesn't work just Rook H7 check
King captures and now you started the
king hunt for those of you who are
interested uh the king will get
checkmated I'm just gonna quickly show
you where that all the way after d for
Queen capture Sunday for this is where
the black king would get checkmated uh
if um if you try to defend the Rook so
King the E8 was played now comes Queen
captures and G8 King to D7 and now
Knight to E5 with check we have King to
D6 now still hoping um uh mamidara will
capture on C8 so maybe Anish can play
some like Rook to F1 and start some
trouble but no mama jar just plays
Knights the D3 and not the bishop is
hanging The Rook is singing and of
course it was in this position on move
30 that Anish giri resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
there you have it that's the power of
beating Magnus in round one uh you you
just um well you you're just
um uh so so inspired that you are able
to create a masterpiece uh like this and
you know just the Anish Place H6 there's
G4 you don't think about it you open up
the position the black queen is all all
the way on the queen side uh you know it
has to work even though the position is
still sort of better for black but I
mean in Rapid who will uh who will
defend this and interestingly in this
position where King tadism was played
you can actually capture the bishop here
I'm just gonna show it because it's fun
and after Rook to F1 check look at this
King to D2 now Rook the F to check King
C3 and there are no more checks and you
just resign I mean uh beautiful position
uh all sorts of nasty ideas being
threatened here I mean just spectacular
uh so after this Knight the D3 Moon Mama
resigned and also Anish resigned in the
beautiful victory for Shakir mamidarov
in round three uh of um uh the aim chest
preliminaries 2022 and uh well it's a
very nice game I'm sure you guys are
interested what about the standings who
is leading after day one I will just say
another back Abu satrov is the leader
and we are going to discuss that a bit
more in future videos so thank you all I
will see you soon and uh have an
excellent rest of your day